heroin welcome to this rapid game 2510
let's see what I can do I was close to
that two thousand mark but I said you
don't get above it somehow not so
difficult in some way because you get
mostly lower rated opponents so let's
just do this we got a scandinavian
defense with Knight f6 that's not an
opening that I know well so I'll just
dumb yeah I'll just play with normal
healthy moves not doing anything fancy
yeah the last couple of days I released
them some of the rapid games and
starting tomorrow we have the the London
chess classics and I'm going to do
around to recap videos showing some
highlights I have to see maybe and go
through all the games quickly just
depends on how the games go maybe I go
to look at one game in detail I don't
know but I'll do some coverage of the
London chest classics also take note if
you are a member of the iso see that i
will be liar for two rounds doing live
broadcasting of the of the event i'll be
on on sunday sunday the sixth this would
be round three where i'll be online with
Grandmaster last bow Hansen from from
Denmark currently in earth in florida
and i'll also be on I think on the 10th
when I'll be covering together with Joe
Benjamin I think this is the right order
and have I have one session with with
Joel and one with them last boy handsome
okay so I'm getting lots of Tempe here
and I'm happy with that gaining time in
an open position cannot be bad he has to
go back to be eight now okay so 93 is
the most natural move here yeah I think
I'd over that spending much time on a
move like that doesn't seem right guys
spent lots of time with his nights there
yeah but this this still looks kind of
playable for black me not not great but
not doesn't look like i should win
outright or so maybe queen 84 actually
that could be an idea if i go queen a
form oh nice got c6
hmm
I guess Bishop g5 go for very quick
development here take stakes are they ed
CD Queen a4 is a bit a bit of a better
version of the Queen a 4 immediately
Queen a for RC six long castles stuff
like that or is that too brutal that
might be
it is very brutal but it is interesting
that leads to interesting play
it looks like a possible way to exploit
my leading development
Bishop d7 I go queen bee three and
attack the b7 pawn 97 96 looks terrible
27 queen bee three also looks weird c6
looks like the normal move that's same
okay the thing is that Queen takes b7
threatens the winds Oh twins material
Katie said if I cheek b7 now is which
bishops is six or queen or 96 oh I will
take
yeah how does he cover the pawn b6 that
looks pretty awkward maybe Bishop c8 but
it makes look that that makes look good
that that hmm I'd move from gypsy aid
makes Bishop d7 look bad so this is the
right kind of sentence here okay Queen
to c8 that was not exactly what I
expected but yeah he wants to Castle can
I somehow prevent that with some
aggressive moves probably not
ok I think I'll just develop I just
wonder where do i go to see for 2d three
that's hard to tell let's play here
Bishop d3 some night a six looked
inconvenient
yeah so rookie one or 95 I think 95
looks very tempting so let's not waste
time them centralized the night there's
also the direct idea of some d6 business
that we can become quite ugly quickly
okay so you put some protection down on
the f7 square root one is the normal
looking move yeah I think I don't let
it's difficult for him to develop him 97
he has to look for discoveries the
bishop on his seven
let be seven i can probably take this
seven key Queen d7 queen bee seven for
some advantage but I don't like to take
127 particularly yeah I don't do it I
don't have a good square to put them put
the night yes playing that
and 97 27 queen p sub lattice bit lame
he's got rugby aid and hmm
that don't see a great mouth him don't
have root d 196 leads nowhere amazing
yeah i mean i think i'm slightly better
after the capture but it feels wrong
Queen takes Queen be some rugby eight
Queens is sick so he cannot take be to a
c7 is also hanging but it didn't feel
like the best possible continuation
Queen c6 dc-6 I'm having this tempo and
the bishop only seven so i will be in
time to prevent the loss of the be to
pawn I just felt that there should be
something more aggressive then this but
it's good of course I'm not complaining
so let's see how to do this now the b3
is a move or Bishop e3 be 3m has one
advantage it gives the bishop on c4 I
very stable square it runs into Bishop
before and moves like that though that
doesn't look dangerous so let's let's go
p3
so we wants to go nitey five blue
yeah certainly you can do that and
there's also 93 in some cases I don't
think that this is particularly
dangerous then do i go a three-year one
do I just ignore the whole thing I think
I cannot ignore it doesn't look like i
can ignore it
yeah i was saving bishop d5 but you can
also um calculate scenarios where I just
returned the pond and it's no reason
though to return it 93 rookie three
atoms I don't really think that this is
so great night before maybe
ok
it looks a bit bit weird night before as
a bit of a strange room for night see to
end hmm
and I have to look out for some aged six
moves in seclusion age 45 can be or h6b
so much for night at Bishop f4 are those
those things can be quite dangerous so
my bishop is attacked should be form
yeah we should be for age six that
doesn't look too great rook c1 also not
looking too great hook c1h six again hmm
I'm not too great
hmm
whom
I don't quite know what to do maybe
Bishop e7 night see 256
that looks pretty decent actually we
should be seven Bishop a form would be
for
yeah let's go pee should be seven I
don't want to pay passing of them night
see to ping I don't believe in bishop p6
should be good for me ok so I'll take
here
tonight a one Bishop c7 should be just
excellent for wide the night on a one is
pretty useless and I have a have two
pawns and fantastic Poland c6 them now I
don't think that night's twist this is
good what he has done him I can also
just take as if he takes the bishop
their c7 and this is pretty good for
white to put it mildly
maybe I'm just winning he could have
defended that much much better I think
so let's see the bishop that's
completely off side so how to do this
not be 5m that wins 96 of the threat
rook c8 rook c1 and 96 1987 next so at
the end of the game we should too maybe
we should be 296 Bishop 86 but now thats
that not saving them either
and at 87 or 96 next
check black resigns yeah it wasn't a
good game i think on my part it should
have been fantastic out of the opening
and somehow couldn't really make it work
I'm pretty optimistic that this was okay
up to here but maybe I have to improve
here and the engine is just taking him
yeah it's simple but probably good yeah
it's probably good Bishop takes Queen
Chinese bishop cheeks 94 and white is
better okay no doubt about that yeah
maybe maybe this check is good yeah this
is looking weird but i don't i'm not
sure i couldn't really exploit it the
engine agrees up to here here here and
now what it wants to play exactly like i
play it but it didn't and gives me a big
advantage probably i'm doing something
wrong here that'd be three move and it's
all seems to be okay not be fine this
stronger though yeah it is stronger I
didn't consider that it all had looks
pretty strong that the bishop doesn't
have a good square at all okay here 83
here oh there should be seven is the
move by the comp and while is much
better no that was completely
out of my radar it's the engines main
line and white wins yeah due to multiple
pressure on f7 get this way but this
actually played it right the engine
gives me a big advantage is the whole
way I was I was kind of unsure if I
missed something or but it doesn't seem
to be an dis dis loose I was thinking
some bishop for something like that I
mean I didn't see anything great for me
but yeah I can also just take I didn't
see anything wait for him is what I was
trying to save it I feel I've held that
it was kind of shaky the engine doesn't
doesn't see anything at all so it seems
it was a good game even though I had
some opportunities to UM to play in a
simpler way especially he had 95 looks
pretty convincing if I get to take the
six the game is essentially over with
the sea porn so the night is probably
inclined to go back and if i go here now
I mean he's much much less active so
much much better version than then the
game is left at porn I have a point up
if I have a pond plus great yeah the
development land and peace coordination
that it should be be close to win okay
thanks for watching